hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in our own time
and culture we often contrast various
motivations for loving and we can talk
about people being superficial lovers
just of appearances looking for people
who are physically attractive and
counter point is that to a whole bunch
of other things that you know we we put
into a sort of grab bag of what's
different like somebody having a great
personality or loving them for their
mind or caring about the real person
often times will contrast the two as if
its body and what is not body that is
the dividing line in PO sanyasis speech
it's a little bit more complex than that
he's going to distinguish two very
different distinct ways of loving two
different types of love in fact he's
also going to bind it up with concerns
about you know male male sexual relation
relations as opposed to male female
sexual relations because really have
anything to say about women being
involved with other women which might be
a bit of an oversight in his speech but
let's see what how he unpacks this
notion of there being two different
kinds of lumps this is in part what he
criticizes the previous speech Phaedrus
was the giver of that for not having
adequate they distinguished we saw
Phaedra says love brings out the best in
everybody Paul sanyasis thing it brings
out the best in some people but in other
people it doesn't do you know that it
may actually bring out the worst in them
so he's going to contrast what he calls
the heavenly or Iranian Aphrodite
against the earthly or pandemic
Aphrodite and he's these are two
goddesses and he says look you know the
goddess Aphrodite is not just one there
is actually two one origin story of
Aphrodite has her in fact being
generated from heaven itself right not
having a birth like other gods or were
creatures or anything like that but
being generated by the heavens now he
glosses over the way that this this
happens in the story who run else who is
the one of these primal beings the mean
sky he is the father of the titans and
one of the titans Kronos will actually
end up taking power and he'll do that in
part by castrating Renaud's and then
taking what he's cut off and throwing it
into the ocean and out of that Aphrodite
comes you know there's that famous
painting that you've probably seen
before I've Aphrodite arising from the
waves that's what she is arising from
but you can still say what there's no
birth their ancient goddess okay we get
that right then we have another goddess
another Aphrodite because the Greeks
were often rather confused about these
origin stories are often more than one
who is the daughter of Zeus as are many
of the gods right and do a and Zeus gets
together the way he typically does
screwing around in his wife by the way
with Dione and boom there you get
another little Goblin who becomes a god
in her own right so part of what house
audience is going to draw from this is
that this got as though the pandemic the
common the vulgar Aphrodite is partaking
equally in the mail and the fee
male and for Pontius the female is
something lower something not quite as
good something that is is not filled
with intellect the way the male is the
heavenly Aphrodite is entirely from or
of the mail this is you know maybe
something questionable about it but here
I'm the only interest in explaining his
position now what this leads to is two
different kinds of love Aphrodite is the
goddess of love or sexual desire
Aphrodisias means all the actions we
tend to think of aphrodisiacs as you
know things we would introduce into the
sexual relation to try to intensify the
greek word off-road easy amines all the
things that are connected with getting
it out with having sex with pursuing
somebody with courting somebody all of
those are part of a frothy zia and the
earthly love he says is the love that is
just oriented towards the body so you
see an attractive person you know could
be there walking down the street or it
could be you're watching a TV show or it
could be your your you know looking at
you know magazines in a checkout line or
in that the special kiosk section that
they have in all these grocery stores
and you know the images that are put on
there usually photoshopped right are
created specifically to arouse desire
and they don't rouse desire by saying oh
my God look at the mind on that person
they are all desire bye-bye you know
featuring physical aspects and this is a
shape of love right there is love that
takes place in you know with just the
body and this can be oriented either
towards man nor towards women presumably
although pisani extent really talked
much about this because he's only
interested in the male perspective we
could talk about you know women being
attracted to men and being attracted
primarily to the body this is maybe a
gap in his discussion right with the
heavenly Aphrodite it's not that there's
no love of the body there's no
attraction to the
d but it doesn't stop just with the
external appearance so it's a love of
the body but also a love of the soul and
he takes this as only possible for for
men to feel towards other men in park is
he's making a whole argument that we
don't need to get into about why you
know the good virtuous lover should be
should be allowed we're going to talk
about that in some other videos in any
case what's most important here is that
there's there's a love of the soul
that's going on so what you know what
can we say is identified with assault
intelligence if you love somebody for
their soul they have to have something
to offer in their soul so you can't just
love somebody for their personality or
for who they are or for their interior
or whatever if they're a complete
dirtbag or if they're stupid or if
they're you know pick whatever else you
like this is the ancient you know Greek
perspective we're looking at and puss
audience is representing it if you're
going to love somebody for their soul
their soul had better have some
remarkable aspects to it like being
intelligent that's the one that he
focuses on most nobility of character
would also play a role in there as well
right and we can contrast that to the
the common love which is not really
attracted to you know things that are
deep like that it's attracted to the
superficial why because the body and how
it's clothed and you know how it's
articulated and all that's right that's
really superficial by definition right
it is the surface it is not what is
inside it is what is outside we could
take this analysis further and say that
you could be attracted to even more
superficial things you know the Greeks
distinguished between the goods of the
body and external goods so if you're
really only interested in somebody
because they have a lot of money or a
fancy car or a nice house or a good bank
account or something like that then that
could fall in here as well but that
might not even be loved by Paul sanyasis
view because there's no erotic desire
there
I suppose we can talk about fetishes and
people heck with respect to that but
that takes us far beyond what he is what
is getting it now this kind of love here
it's not that it's simply bad so to love
somebody or desire them for their body
in a superficial way is not necessarily
bad but it's not good either it could go
towards hoodie actions or it could go
towards bad actions there's really no
way to tell which way it's going to go
that's pozadia at this point he's not
saying it's just bad he's saying well
it's a you know mixture of good and bad
why is this because it doesn't actually
understand what it's about it's not
based on knowledge is not based on
anything intellectual so the person who
is motivated by this kind of love just
sort of accent random they might end up
doing really good things of course they
might end up doing really bad things as
a result as well there's no way to tell
this is one reason to why he says look
you shouldn't be loving people who are
you know not really fully developed
because you don't know how they're going
to turn out when they do develop right
now by contrast the this this heavenly
love it leads to only good action action
that is right action that is noble
action that is based on understanding
what it does and desiring what is good
this is going to lead to a very
important effect over time when we when
we r contrasting these things against
each other we haven't yet introduced the
notion of you know a life span the
person who only loves the body the body
is something mutable it changes over
time of course the soul changes over
time to a personality whatever you want
to say but the body changes much more
quickly and if you think about the kind
of beauty that's associated solely with
the body it's not very long-lasting is
it you don't think about a face right
you get wrinkles quite quickly and you
know we do you know in our society we're
a little bit
biased towards men we let men get away
with a lot more wrinkles than we do
women but even so you see a lot of guys
going in for plastic surgery why
precisely so that they can be attractive
to this kind of love here that's what
Pausanias would say here right here gets
grey gets white falls out he'll lose it
right you know there's all sorts of
other aspects to the body to the you
know the body of a 16 year old who's in
good shape will not look like the body
of a 45 year old who's in good shape the
45 year old is inevitably going to be
stockier right and that's the way it
should be but to the person who's only
concerned with this that's not going to
maintain the force of desire so what
happens well the basis for the
relationship eventually disappears and
this is what leads to all sorts of bad
behavior on people's part you know I I'm
going to you know love you forever we
get married we take all these vows to
each other but it's just based on
physical attractiveness and suddenly
somebody goes through a midlife crisis
and now they're chasing the youths right
the people who appear to have a better
body but who are probably not all that
much on the ball as a matter of fact if
they're going out with somebody who
clearly is in the middle of a midlife
crisis they are probably at least from
this perspective oriented towards the
wrong things themselves right by
contrast and pontius has himself in mind
with this because he's actually a lover
of Agatha he's an older man who
maintains a relationship with Agathon
over the course of their lives the lover
who is motivated by the heavenly
Aphrodite by the kind of love that comes
along with that that's oriented not just
towards the body but even more towards
the personality the mind the soul the
inner being of the person not only is
going to lead to good action and to
friendship but it's going to be a
constant type of love it's going to
remain
as people age as people go through
changes it's going to probably grow in
that case so like it but here the lover
who loves on this basis is a constant
and thus reliable lover they're not
going to throw over the person that
they're involved with just because the
new shiny model is in town your people
talk that way if people talk that way
they're clearly over here on this side
right notice what we got here on this
side the person is not really being
treated entirely as a person on this
side the person is being treated as a
person and you know the tragic part of
this speech is that many people may not
be capable of anything other than this
pandemic aphrodite driven sort of love